so now I want to talk about a more
specific reaction to Trump's tyranny
letter we already talked about the sort
of legal argument being made by Donald
Trump's lawyers as to why he is
literally tyrannically above the law now
to put a sort of cartoonish spin on it
Trump's lawyer Rudy Giuliani is straight
up saying that not even the president
shooting James Comey would bring
consequences okay
he cannot be indicted for murder as
president the first thing would be
successful impeachment and only then
could a case be brought against the
president according to Rudy Giuliani and
what this is effectively saying is that
as president the president is legally
immortal for lack of a better term if
and only if you first impeach a
president can you then try to hold them
accountable for crimes that they
committed as president and norm Eisen
who is Obama's White House ethics lawyer
says that this is self-evidently
incorrect and that there is actually no
blanket protection for presidents from
criminal prosecution period does anyone
actually believe that this is what the
founding fathers intended a president
who could murder people while president
and face no consequences and this is
when we've got to step back from nuts
like Rudy Giuliani and go to the legal
scholars not Trump's lawyers but go to
the legal scholars and basically the
answer is it's complicated it's very
complicated but it's definitely not
freedom to murder people that the
president of the US has at least not
right now so Rudy Giuliani is correct in
one sense which is you first have to
impeach a president to hold them
accountable for major wrongdoing related
to the job of being president right so
for things that would be serious enough
to warrant impeachment that relate to
the president's job as president
colluding with foreign powers in a
treasonous way high crimes and
misdemeanors as the phrase goes you need
impeachment first that's true we know
that the President does have broad
immunity for example from deaths
resulting from a decision to go to war
right if you say hey you launched a war
and 4,000 people died that's murder
no the Constitution does provide those
protections where it gets complicated is
prosecution of a president for crimes
that they committed before they were
president
for crimes committed while being
president that don't relate to their
official capacity as president this is
not protected based on the scholarship
that I've read so the president can't
actually go around shooting people and
then say unless you impeach the guy you
can't charge them with murder that
appears to not be the case now there's
an obvious question which is well where
is the line between an official act and
a non official act by the president I
admit that there's a blurry line but the
murder of individuals with a gun would
not be protected
in the way that Rudy Giuliani is
claiming based on everything that I've
read about this issue yeah can we just
touch on how this is such a gross thing
to say because Comey is perhaps Trump's
biggest political opponent yeah and
Trump has an army of sycophants so you
know if the president's lawyer saying
this willy-nilly that could inspire
someone to take action upon this I know
he's probably alluding to the Trump
could shoot someone on Fifth Avenue
comrades any voters but it's not the
right thing to say no it's it's we've
talked about stochastic terrorism which
is obviously if someone goes and shoots
Comey you're not gonna actually get Rudy
Giuliani on any kind of criminal charges
but with enough crazy people sycophants
as pat is saying following Trump it's
not completely outside of the realm of
possibility that someone might be
inspired to do that at this point in the
meantime send me your thoughts send me
your best explanations as far as what
the answer is to this question could
Trump murder someone and just get away
with it while President I believe the
answer is no we're working on lining up
an interview actually with a true legal
scholar to explore the answer to this
issue more specifically I believe the
answer is Rudy Giuliani is off his
rocker and doesn't know what the hell
he's talking about quick break back
after this today's episode of the
program is made possible in part by Cody
a new innovative cryptocurrency and
online payment platform that's setting
out to revolutionize how payments are
sent and received online what Cody
stands for is currency of the internet
and most Kryptos out there today simply
weren't designed for online payments and
the goal of the Cody crypto is to
achieve an infrastructure for online
payments that simple transparent
trustworthy instantaneous and scalable
which no blockchain for payments has
really achieved to date so Cody is
aiming to be that missing piece of the
puzzle a crypto and platform actually
designed with online payments in mind if
you're watching this on youtube you can
find out more about Cody and their ICO
by using the links below the video this
is not financial advice and should not
be interpreted as such and everybody
should do their own research on any
project that they're interested in